frankie montos is on the mound for the
oakland a's
you can see on the season in eight
starts he has a 4.93 era
had a rough start to the season in that
month of april he had a 6.20 era much
better in this month of may and he's
been actually
doing really well at home with a
three-in-one record jose altuve to start
things off for the astros batting 307
364 on base percentage four homers 17
rbis
the first pitch of the ball game and
altuve lifts it in the air pretty deep
to left
pender is going back at the wall looking
up see you later
a first pitch lead off homer for jose
altuve
his second lead off homer this year one
nothing astro
well i don't i don't think frankie
montos had any idea that altuve would
swing at the first pitch if he threw the
breaking pitch so he threw the slider
and now tubey was sitting on it
and he blasted it to left field that's
how you start a game and the astros have
a runner on first with one out alvarez
second in the league and hitting with
that 346 average
swing he struck him out good off speed
pitch by frankie montauk
so first and second for correa astros
leading one nothing on altuve's lead off
homer
a little punch shot to right that's
going to drop in for a hit
bregman around third he's going to score
heading to third base is guriel carlos
correa
an rbi base hit to right field in the
astros league two to nothing
zach grinky you can forget about
everything he has done
he's been very good for the astros and
the acquisition of grenkey was
outstanding and forget about the opening
day start because
he didn't do anything the first four
games he'll face mark canna here
swinging to miss
frankie gets canna again first out it's
a strikeout for that
two outs nobody on for oakland in the
bottom of the first here's ramon lariano
strike three caught at the knees grenkey
paints one on the outside
corner here's milo straw the number
eight hitter the pitch by frankie and
that's
on the outside corner ring him up good
pitch fastball
96 101 and frankie trying to get the
small game on track
so here's mauldin otto here's the fish
to maldonado now and he takes ring him
up back-to-back strikeouts looking both
on fastballs and maldonado is down
so pin your 227 he's five for 22 on the
year
frankie delivers and the 2-2 on the way
and that swung on a shot into right for
a base hit a clean single altuve went
diving to his left not even close
on the rim of the alpha grass and pinder
delivers the a's first hit
and murphy is coming up and with all the
traffic the astros have had so
far it's only a two-nothing game murphy
lines one headed for the corner
pinder hits the bag at second ball's
picked up by brantley
they're gonna wave pinder home here
comes the throw to the plate it is
offline the a's are on the board
sean murphy doubles down the left field
line scoring pinder from first
and is two to one houston martin
maldonado will start the fourth inning
for houston they lead a 2-1 he's
overshift on maldonado he
swings and skies went to shallow left
elvis is out
and pinder is in and chad will call
everybody off he'll make a two-handed
catch
here comes altuve
[Applause]
he skies this one on the infield where
chapman
is staying with it
so that is the second out here in the
bottom of the fourth
so here's bregman he's walked and scored
and bounced to third
he struck him toss gets his sixth
strikeout brantley is stranded we're
headed to
the bottom of the fourth inning lariano
will lay things off for oakland here in
the bottom of the fourth innings
swinging a miss zach gets him with a
fastball
grenkie picks up his third strikeout two
of them against l'oreal
rolled him to sleep with the slider and
a couple of curveballs and then sped it
past him at 91 to get the strikeout
as much as he throws to any hitter that
time it's a curveball
sent high in the air into center field
mile straw puts it away there's chapman
so two quick outs for drinking
but very strange to go over six with two
runners in scoring position
and score that many slow curve has
popped up shallow right tucker calls
them all off
makes the catch and that's a one two
three for granky we'll go to the fifth
in oakland
who catches garcia so murphy is done for
the night let's hope he's okay and
that's swung on and he'll drive into
center going back lauriano still going
back has to play about 10 feet from the
track
and dead center field he makes the catch
one out
moriano backs up again a little bit
further this time but he's under it
so two away here in the top of the fifth
inning and that'll bring up correa
in the pitch and that's swung on it up
fly ball right field playable for
biscotti
long run toward right center he's gonna
get there and he makes the catch and
frankie
one two three fifth and halfway through
a ball game tonight bottom of the fifth
inning zach reinke
delivers to chad pinder to two swing get
a mess got him on a slider away
fourth strikeout for grinky and there is
one away that's why his control's been
so good here's a ramus garcia getting
his first played appearance tonight he
replaced sean murphy at catcher in the
fifth murphy left after being hit by a
few foul tips
here's the one-two swing and a miss
crazy movement on that change up down
and in to out nobody on for piscotti
grounded out his first time
here's a 2-2 to piscotti swing and a
mess got him on a fastball away
zach reinke strikes out the side here's
kenna and trying to solve the mystery
that is
zach cranky and that's going to be a
base hit
hannah drops it into left field he kicks
away from bentley
and cannon's going to try for second and
he's saying the ball past el tube
durielle's backing it up so the a's have
the tying run in scoring position with
one out and jed lowry at the plate he's
over two tonight
called third strike outside corner lowry
doesn't like the call
but it was close on the o2 pitch and
grenkey picks up strikeout number seven
now two out to runner on second for
ramon lariano
ground ball towards third bregman
with the play to first pick by eule and
that will do it for the a's in the sixth
inning
a little two-out rally here for the
astros with a walk and a hit
gotta give guriel a shot now runners
take off here's the pitch
and that's driven good one left field
for yuley
is it off the wall bregman scores
alvarez scores dooley into second with a
two-run
double and the biggest hit of the night
gives the astros a 4-1 lead
pitching chain sergio romo facing carlos
correa
that's a line drive base hit in the
center field that'll score a run
astros lead 5-1 correa thought about
heading to second he'll hold up
with an rbi single here's chapman he's
over two
three singles and a double the double
scored the only run for the eighth
swing and a miss grenkey picks up his
eighth strikeout
of the game season high man he is just
steamrolling through oakland with two
out curveballs grounded to the left side
bregman's got it on the backhand and he
throws him out
for a one two three inning for granky so
that is a great shutdown inning for
grinke
in this series they scored five last
night five more tonight
with four outs to work with brantley up
the middle base hit to center field he
has a three-hit game this one will drive
in mile straw
brantley with an rbi single now makes it
a six to one game
bases will be loaded for yuley guriel
yuli line drive base hit to left field
one run scores bregman will score yuli
guriel to second base he will be
safe at second he's doing everything
right
a four hit game four rbis and a little
swim move
and the astros lead is eight to one back
to back innings with two run
doubles for guriel you said it mr base
is loaded guerrielle
zach carries an 8-1 lead into the bottom
of the eighth inning
and he's on one on andrews kyle tucker
makes the play back has retired
17 of 18. he is through eight innings
with an 8-1 lead ken emanuel takes over
here facing the top of the lineup
breaking ball and that's lifted out in
the short center
going out is robel garcia he's called
off by straw who makes the catch and
that is the ball game
the houston astros are a half game
out of first place as they defeat the
oakland a's tonight by a final
of eight to one